[Musique]
des images qui ont choqué le pays
des scènes filmées exposé au grand jour
alors qu'à peu près tout le monde a une
caméra à portée de main faut-il équiper
les policiers
c'est ce qu'a fait il ya huit ans la
police régionale de kennebecasis nuit
les visons les caméras depuis 2002
c'est le premier corps policier du
nouveau brunswick à exiger le port des
caméras par ses 39 policiers d'après moi
il y a beaucoup davantage
il est beaucoup de transparence avec le
public quand il y à un plainte contre un
policier
on peut réviser les vidéos et même
montré la vidéo au monde le public du
canada l'usagé qu'il en a fait un mini
d'autres services policiers comme celui
de fredericton a emboîté le pas il y a
deux qui sont la solution complète mais
je pense que ça aide a donné un aperçu
de la situation que ci que je peux en
avoir un et demi douzaine ou tu crèves
quand même un club pro dance je pense ça
serait bien les enregistrements vidéos
sont parfois utilisés pour corroborer le
rapport des policiers ils servent aussi
pour évaluer la conduite des agents et
maintenant nous sommes en train de
remplacer toutes les caméras avec les
éditions nouvelles le chef est si
convaincu de la valeur ajoutée de ces
caméras que son service est en train
d'acquérir les modèles dernier cri
le coup est cher mais d'après moi ça
vaut la peine
une caméra comme celle ci peut coûter
entre 650 et 950 dollars sans compter
les logiciels et les frais de stockage
des enregistrements c'est pas une
solution magique des problèmes que nous
façon maintenant dans une société qui
est
maintenant discuter au public mais je
pense que ça offre beaucoup de valeur
le nouveau système est entièrement
synchroniser les vidéos se télécharge
automatiquement sans fil grâce à des
moniteurs installé au poste de police
dès que les gyrophares s'allume ou que
la porte de la voiture de patrouille
s'ouvrent les caméras s'activent
d'elle-même
mais ce serait pas une dépense d'argent
judicieuse
à mon humble avis si l'idée refait
surface au canada depuis quelques
semaines cette spécialiste des affaires
policières n'est pas convaincu que c'est
la meilleure stratégie à adopter
à la lumière des études qui ont été
effectués au canada
il n'y a pas de résultats en bas là
c'est un outil supplémentaire oui un
témoin neutre diront certains mais
encore faut-il dit elle que les caméras
répondent aux objectifs pour lesquels
elles ont été implantées les caméras ne
permettent pas de diminuer les possibles
traitement différentiel auprès de
certaines populations
les caméras ne permettent pas de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui mène à des
interventions où il ya des usages la
force qui non appropriés en tout cas au
nouveau brunswick
l'idée fait son chemin avec des
inconvénients
je peux proposer un événement je peux
compenser les inconvénients à la lumière
d arrestation filmée et partager sur les
réseaux sociaux
les autorités policières devront donc
déterminer si l'investissement est
justifié et surtout si les caméras sont
la meilleure façon d'accroître la
transparence et la confiance envers le
public ici geneviève normes à
radio-canada moteur